what's up guys bang bang huge week in
the macroeconomic environment and with
Bitcoin first up the Federal Reserve
they are committed to Bringing inflation
down they went ahead and they raised
interest rates another 25 basis points
this brings us to a 5.25 to 5.5 interest
rate which is a 22-year high when they
said that they were going to crash asset
prices and get inflation under control
they weren't playing around now of
course this past week we also saw
another bank failure pack West getting
bought by one of their smaller Rivals
Bank of California now the reason why
that's important is because nobody cared
did you read about it the mainstream
media barely even talked about it we now
have gotten to a point where there are
so many bank failures happening that
nobody cares and nobody pays attention
but Bitcoin also does not care about any
of that nonsense in the financial
markets it's looking at the economy and
it's laughing at it what do I mean
Bitcoin is up about 80 to start the year
and 55 of all Bitcoin has not moved in
two years that's 55 percent of the just
over 19 million Bitcoin in circulating
Supply that has not moved in two years
those are long-term holders who are
holding the asset and they ain't giving
it up then if we go and we look around
the world we see that BlackRock they
publish this paper a couple authors from
over at the big big financial
institution and they say that the
optimal Bitcoin allocation is over 80
percent it's like 85 percent based on
their mathematics now of course I'm not
Einstein you're not either but if
BlackRock says it's true then obviously
it must be true the Bitcoin network has
now settled 110 trillion dollars of
transaction volume so the next time that
your uncle at Thanksgiving dinner or
that annoying kid down the street tells
you no one uses Bitcoin remind them well
enough people used it to settle 110
trillion dollars worth of transactions
then let's run on up right to Capitol
Hill Congress has now passed one of the
crypto regulation bills this is a big
deal because we not only saw Republicans
but also six Democrats cross over the
aisle and start having a little
bipartisanship it's about time we also
started working together and trying to
figure out how we could create a
regulatory environment to keep
Innovation here in America now there's
two other big names this week who had
something to say about Bitcoin first we
have Tim Draper Tim Draper's been a long
time Bitcoin bull he's been talking
about Bitcoin prices in the hundreds of
thousands for years but now Tim Draper's
taking it a step further he says that he
believes Bitcoin will be superior to all
other Fiats here's what Tim had to say
but it's also going to rise above Fiat
and I think uh it's just better
technology I mean having to have a bank
and a government decide on what currency
is good
um is not as it is not as effective as
having
um a Bitcoin where you you have a
trusted third party which is
hundreds of thousands of nodes out there
checking to make sure that the
transaction was done properly so I think
uh it's just better safe for technology
and eventually uh the rest of the world
will uh come on and Tim he's not the
only one with big Grand Ambitions for
Bitcoin we also had Robert F Kennedy Jr
the presidential candidate who's got a
lot of hot takes all over Twitter he
came out and he said that his plan is to
back US dollars with Bitcoin now this
may seem like an insane idea and I don't
even know if I necessarily agree with it
as a good idea but here is exactly what
Robert F Kennedy Jr will do if he
becomes your president exempting Bitcoin
from from uh from exchange taxes
uh is uh is almost a perfect analogy for
that and we ought to be doing that in
the United States secondly
uh the Kennedy administration will begin
to back the US dollar with real finite
assets such as gold silver platinum and
Bitcoin
um which is the world's hardest liquid
asset to strengthen the US dollar and
guarantee its continued success as a
world Reserve currency
uh this will include U.S treasury bills
notes and bonds
um my plan would be to start very very
small perhaps one percent of issued
t-bills would be backed by hard currency
by Gold Silver Platinum or Bitcoin
um and then uh uh depending on the
outcome we would increase that annually
and what this will do is it will it will
ironically
we will be able to use Bitcoin to help
save the US dollar
you know I was in uh in Cleveland 10
days ago in the Lee Harvard District of
Cleveland which is one of the poor
sisters including like absolutely the
business in that District
um it's almost all African-American
we're almost completely wiped out by the
coveted epidemic there are a few
remaining businesses and they are now
being wiped out not by inflation of
course everybody the poor being
decimated by inflation this country and
people on fixed incomes
um and you know and Bitcoin would be a
hedge against that uh but they're also
being they're being wiped out now by
high interest rates which is the remedy
the government's remedy the fed's remedy
for inflation
uh the high interest rates are devalued
uh the value of of t-bills which are
um uh and so
many of the local and Community Banks
that serve those communities are now
hoarding their liquid assets they're
hoarding their t-bills and they're not
making loans and I met with an
African-American woman who had one of
the few surviving businesses in that
community
uh that uh it's a sausage business that
had been in her family for 80 years
and she's closing it now because she
cannot get a small loan even a small
loan
from a local bank they're simply
unavailable because the banks are not
putting any uh liquidity into those
communities
and we need to change that and one of
the ways to change that is to strength
and uh the perception and the value of
t-bills so that they do not degrade like
that and this is a way of doing that and
so and Bitcoin is part of the basket of
hard currencies that I think that that
the Kennedy administration is going to
encourage
uh the the proliferation of and uh and
the provocation of and I mentioned many
reforms that I'm committed to in my
Bitcoin 2023 speech including
self-custody your wallet should be your
own uh the capacity of of people to run
of American citizens while there's run
Bitcoin or to run on nodes inside their
own homes
uh the the policy of Industry neutral
regulation of energy
uh and and and my administration's
mission
of making America the Global Hub of
cryptocurrency particularly Bitcoin
as a means of incentivizing Greater
investment in in green and energy and
renewable energy production and
attracting uh engineering investment and
Innovation to our country all right I
hope you enjoyed this Roundup of what's
been going on in the Bitcoin world and
the macro economy there's lots of
uncertainty in the future but what we
see is a highly illiquid market and
there's a ton of people politicians
large financial institutions and Retail
investors who continue to be interested
in this asset my guess is that over a
long period of time Bitcoin will
continue to produce block after block
after block of transactions doing
exactly what it was designed to do
that's the beauty of Bitcoin in a world
of chaos in a world of noise Bitcoin
doesn't care